The latest now in our breaking news.
The U.S.
military has shot down
another high altitude object,
this tank near Lake Huron.
This would be the third
object brought down in as many days.
Let's go now to CNN's Arlette Sines
at the White House.
Our let
you have new details about this object.
What are you learning?
Yeah, Paula,
a senior
administration official
providing some new details to myself,
Natasha Bertrand and Phil
Mattingly detailing what exactly
this unidentified object look like now.
It was flying at about 20,000 feet
when it was shot down.
It had been flying over part of
Michigan's Upper Peninsula
and then was nearing Lake Huron
when ultimately
it was taken down by fighter aircraft.
And what this senior administration
official described
is that
it had an octagonal shape
and there were strings hanging from it,
but with no discernible payload.
Another source
who was briefed on the matter
also shared that description.
And while the U.S.
has said
that they can't
happen, determined
whether they're
whether there was
any intelligence collection
capabilities to this object,
they are simply not ruling that out
at this moment.
Now, this object was first detected
by Noor Rod and Noor Cam just last night.
There was some radar contact
that was made in the US
that sent some fighter aircraft
to try to take a look
and see if there was anything out there
last night
that they did not see an object
and ultimately believed
that it was an anomaly, a radar anomaly.
But then today
they reacquired
that radar contact and found this object
that was going from Wisconsin over in
to Michigan.
Now, there were concerns
about the height of this aircraft.
It was flying at 20,000 feet
and also its path.
So there had been concerns
about what it might mean
for civilian aircraft, but officials
say that it did not pose
any imminent threat
to people on the ground.
But ultimately, President Biden
followed the advice
of his military leaders
and ordered that this unidentified object
be shot down.
So that is what transpired today.
But just a step back.
This is just the latest
in a series of remarkable events
over the course of the last eight days.
This is the fourth time that the U.S.
has shot down
an aerial object
in North American airspace,
starting with that Chinese spy balloon
which traversed across the country.
For days
and was ultimately shot down
off the Carolina coast.
Now, there is this trio
of unidentified objects
with very few descriptors
and big questions
about where exactly they came from
and who they belong to.
The two objects
that were shot down
on Friday
and then Saturday,
we still have very limited details
in what exactly
these objects contained and looked like.
Officials here have said
that they were smaller than that
Chinese spy balloon
that was shot down
off the waters of the East Coast.
But certainly so many questions
for this administration.
As we have just seen.
Unidentified object
after an unidentified object
entering U.S. airspace.
And there's questions
about where they came from
and what exactly it all means.
So many questions are left sides.
Thank you.
And let's talk
more about this
with CNN military analyst, retired U.S.
Air Force Force
Colonel Cedric
Leighton and CNN's
national security analyst
Juliette Kayyem. All right.
Colonel, thank you for being with us.
What is your reaction to this?
Well, this is really interesting.
And our reporting is
is really piqued my interest,
because what you're seeing here
is something that we
I don't think we've seen before
and octagonal object.
So I don't know if that's the payload
or if that's actually the balloon or
the propulsion system or,
you know, something else like that.
So we don't have very many details,
but these are the kinds of questions
that we definitely have to be asking.
And then the other thing that
I thought
was interesting
from this octagonal object.
We have strings coming out.
The strings could be all kinds of things.
But I'm looking at the possibility
of those strings
being antennas of one type or another,
either for receiving
or for transmitting information.
Sheet.
So that's the kind of step
that we have to analyze,
have to have the DOD
and other forensic specialists
analyze this
and really take a look at
what this system actually is,
how it connects
with other
the other systems
that were shot down earlier.
If it does connect at all.
Those are the kinds of questions
that I have right now.
Else and one other thing, if I may.
And that's the low ELT,
relatively low altitude
that this thing was flying at.
12,000 feet is absolute
lutely within
the realm of commercial aircraft.
And that's extremely dangerous
from a commercial aviation perspective.
And the skies over
Michigan are fairly well populated.
So it's definitely something
that needs to be taken care of.
And Juliette,
I want to get your reaction to this.
Another day, another shoot down of
the so-called object.
And so
I want to put this in the categories
of what we know and what we don't know.
So what we know
is that since the Chinese balloon
incident a week ago and learn of other
infiltrations
by the Chinese of the balloon
in years past,
essentially NORAD's,
NORTHCOM and other agencies essentially
what were you call
opened up
the aperture of what
they were looking for.
So they are
they're getting lots of positives
that they did not get before
most of that is going to be known
to known the airplanes, whatever it
whatever it may be.
But there are now going to be lots
more things that sort of raise
the level of concern.
So so that's the first thing we know.
These
these positives
were anticipated more positive.
What we can't answer now is,
is this sort of bigger aperture
picking up
lots of stuff
that has essentially been forgiven
sort of
around in the skies,
whatever else it is,
because they didn't pose a threat
or is it part of something organized
for whatever surveillance I do want to.
So so we don't know.
And I would just want to pick up on
on what the congressman
who was on before us
to speculate about China
in all of these incidents
is just it's it's I'm sorry.
It is just not right right now.
We do not know what these objects are.
They are two are described as VW sized.
One is now of tango.
We we don't know if there's
balloons attached to them.
So we need to just sort of understand
what's going on.
There is a
there's a wider lens of surveillance
that is picking up things.
We don't quite know what they are.
And our tolerance for it
after what happened with China is lower.
We're going to shoot it down
if it is unmanned, if it is it
if it's hurting commercial
or a threat to commercial aviation,
and if shooting it down
will not harm Americans in the homeland,
that is essentially
what's going on
at the speculation
is really premature at this stage.
And Colonel,
you talked a little bit
about civilian airspace.
Clearly, these could potentially pose
a threat to civilian aviation.
Is there any way to really secure
the skies against these kinds of objects?
Well, it's certainly a challenge, Paula.
And, you know,
we look at
how we've secured the skies in the past
we've sometimes used draconian measures
such as shutting things down
in the wake of nine 11, for example,
until we had a reasonable handle on
what was flying in our airspace.
I certainly
don't advocate anything like that
at this particular point
in time, though,
the danger to commercial aviation is,
I would say, minimal at this point.
But it is something that has to be taken
into account.
And airmen of all types, civilian
as well as military,
have to be on the lookout
for unusual objects.
Right now.
I think the heightened awareness
on the part of everybody
becomes really important.
But having an iron clad, you know,
control mechanism for face,
that's practically an impossibility.
But we can certainly do a better job
knowing what's in the air.
And I think North has certainly dealt
with a ton at this point in time,
a little bit late,
but still better late than never.